символом санкти нове протистояння
москви і брюсселя став сир росія була
його імпорту рам нам батьківщину світлі
головну причину і ті, і імпорту за
важливості булан з зараз urvan це за
стирили сироварні
чому берша підлозі війни у ​​sexs ревду
руси і постукала з Європи pprc цифра
близька до нуля як святе зростання від нині з
російської вич вади ви рідні 100 сиру
алла крафті ринку 100 тобі нею піцу
немає відпалити авто за сир у Росії видають
сирний продукт і пий робите за я
пензлем по домівках того заданий мороз
стату ви рівні 100 сирних продуктів на
заросло на 24 сотки хоча за нашими
даним його на доросло на витрати ну і до
чого над росла більше привеству рівні
твориш-то сировину зменшено зросли менше
протезні печіння кістки та зрощення ціни
позначилася монастирях
результатом досвіду ваня фонду грому
пекельного та doom до квітня донована
прикиньте ціп'яка 75 сотих громадян РФС
хвалить за право дженні embargo авось
призначення санкційних продуктів у Росії
до є і наші радикальні заходи
Петро миють ріжки далі як-40 адже сотки
досвідчених мажестиці щоб залишалося про
ти russia's пряма за барону пармезан у
то моцарелла яковлєв патріотизму
підприємств відсікай обидва пильного заняття
люби а дживан і завалювалася ти сукню
з партнером з Європи мам були нас
всякого в них не до світла технології
бренди ресурси
а он і був і душі затікала не в тому ще
б вийти на російський ринок
ми були вже на фінальній стадії
за право джанабу пильної санкції
відомо сторони взяли паузу
агенція хижа вчіться на тебе санкції
chania менше до 2017 раку каррі лист у
руси і також неодноразово натикало ще
обмазували заходи дев'ятому дому та робот
ставку на імпортозаміщення
експорт і таку перспективу з turbo
вані тут ми ж молода sweet
імпортозаміщення продукт 7 10 року
even у зірку колапс економіки та
ризику лупу вершині а я кістки жити а це
ще сьогодні російська влада на мага
реалізувати і з панамський канал ви
витрачали куб у хороший і нічого знайду
тягнути проте у кремля поважають у ж за
10 уроки в русі можливо
повністю замінить і імпортні архіви
продукти